hello everyone I'm Alex this is loon we
represent typi we're in open source
python Library the goal is to deploy
your data projects on the web using
python
only I'm going to do a few slides and
then will do a few demos maybe we'll
have time for some questions and we
should be done in about 40
minutes so let's get
started the problem we wanted to address
with tyi is the low success rate of data
projects uh about 13% of data projects
actually make it into production while
companies are spending billions of
dollars on these
projects there are multiple causes to
this problem uh the main one is talents
so to do a data project you don't only
need to be good in statistics or data or
math you also need devop skills because
someone's got to host your project and
serve it to users and you also really
need frontend skills
it doesn't matter if you have the best
algorithm or best model in the world if
no one can see it or use it no one's
going to use
it um generally uh what we see in data
teams they either don't have all of
these skills or they have these skills
but they're very separated the issue
with that is that the data engineer will
have huge tunnel vision he won't think
about the user because that's the front
end gu um
job and generally he won't think about
user feedback he won't think about
serving data he'll just do the model on
his own and send it to someone else
ideally we would want to for the data
engineer to have all of these skills so
he can instantly send something to the
end user get user feedback very early on
into development and make the project
succeed another cause is projects uh in
data generally take too long or are too
costly uh the main issue we find is uh
people people don't anticipate the
duration of one of these projects
generally they think that the biggest uh
time cost will be uh making the model uh
making the algorithm in reality it's
generally deploying your model serving
monitoring uh Gathering data on user
feedback uh implementing Bud fixes
Etc so I've talked about the problem we
wanted to address and two of the causes
of that problem now our solution our
solution is tyi typi we're an open
source python Library so you can pip
install tyi
um a part of our product deals with
making front end really easily so here I
have some simple python
code um I import typei in my code I have
an integer and a PS data frame uh one
way we Define pages is using markdown
there are over ways like more perenic
ways uh here I just Define a slider
that's connected to my integer and I
Define a chart that's connected to my
data I press run and in 17 lines of code
I have a dynamic web page with a slider
that interacts with
data why is this useful first in terms
of talents well we've just developed a
web application in full python only
python we didn't need to Outsource any
front end skills in terms of time and
cost that reduces your required text
textt to python only that means if you
have a data team they'll be able to do
front end we also deployed this in 17
lines of code try doing the same thing
in react it's going to take more
structure more
code the biggest Advantage is we can put
the user faster in the loop so as if
you're a data engineer as soon as you
have an algorithm working you put it in
in in my bad in an interface and you can
send it to your user the user can play
around with it it and you get user
feedback very early in the development
cycle um we have another part of tyy
that deals with data
orchestration so first of all we have a
graph based editor of data pipelines um
in VSS code it's a vs code extension so
this is a simple machine learning
pipeline we clean data we do a
prediction and an evaluation uh the blue
nodes are data nodes they store python
objects SQL servers um CSV files and the
orange nodes are test nodes so these are
python function that transform data into
new
data uh we also have pre-built uh
interface elements uh so you can send
this to theend user and theend user is
able to change the inputs of the data
pipeline executed see what ran
successfully see the errors and they can
also visualize the
outputs once again why is this useful in
terms of talents we have an interface
where end users can manage their data
pipelines this once again puts the user
in the loop early so as soon as you have
a data pipeline working you put it in
that framework you send this to the user
and he can instantly play around with
the inputs uh use his own serving data
and see what works what doesn't by
visualizing
outputs we also have a ual approach to
pipelines which generally requires less
experience uh in terms of time and cost
uh tyy saves your pipelines results and
some kind of
registry uh this is useful because you
don't lose information we don't rerun
what does not need to be so we have a
caching system for example here we have
a clean data task the second time you're
going to run this pipeline we won't run
clean data automatically because we can
use the cached clean data set and and
also it's really easy to plug into these
data nodes most common data sources that
you use in
companies so I've talked about the
problem we want to to address it causes
and how tiby our solution resolves them
now I'm going to talk about more
concrete
results so we went to see an Mar which
is a big French retailer and they wanted
to do a cash flow management app the
problem is they didn't have the skills
in house to do this so their first
option was they outsourced it they went
to external company um and for 600k four
of their guys and four of the outsourc
guys and 8 months they had their app so
it's fine but 600k 8
months we went to see their team and we
told them well you guys are data
Engineers so you know python let us help
you do the same app but using your own
team members so we only two of their
team members 60k and 2 months they had
an app that respected the same
requirements so that's really the main
leverage of typei we use uh people that
you already you we use skills that are
already in your team it takes less time
and
money um I'm done with this presentation
I'm going to let Floy on to some
technical
demos uh so what I'm going to show you
is uh some use cases that we umly with
II so just some T and I'm going to show
you some La coding what is the behind it
you can write your first application and
how all this back end configuration
works with data your task something that
I will show you just now okay so so this
first application was built in five um
the goal is not only to show the
application just to show how interactive
it is what kind of um well websites well
we application you can create with typi
so you can create cre a single page
application that looks like this where
you have some stock price analysis or
you can change the stock price B of data
that you want to use and they can
predict on and you have all the
information that you want on the stock
um well all the different values and
then the prediction that have here so
the goal is not really to show you that
uh the goal is more to show you that
this was created in just one lines of
code with tyi so this why we say that is
really low code it's very easy so we
just code you can create a single page
dashboard where you can see your data
where you can t to with it where you can
predit use some model and then you can
deoy it same thing so like it was just a
single page dashboard but this is
another page that was created
application that was created with II
where same thing um this is like C
dashboard where you can see all the
information on C like cases the TS all
of these things and same thing it was
created just in a few days inst really
easy to do the same thing um we want to
create easily full web application that
can be with page with user um for like
anyone any P developer so now that you
have seen this I'm going to show you the
logic behind it how you can write your
own type by application so what you do
like I said well like said it is a
python package so open source is free
just do p inst typi and you are free to
go and create your first application so
what have done here is py I'm going to
import it with this G element and in
this G I'm going to put my page so
there's M ways to create your page here
what I'm doing is I'm using the m t to
do it so I'm sure it's good
here so I have some string that follows
the so asht means that this is going to
be title and will be in and it's going
to
run it's going to to create me a local
server with my application running with
just this to put that here and as you
can see I have M down so of course it's
not really interesting here I prise but
it's going to be more um interesting
what you CU yeah I don't like connect
with my pyth variables I have just some
text if I want maybe to connect to this
value 10 is integer well what I'm going
to do is use tyy res elements the typ
five elements have always the same um
syntax it's inferior than five then you
put the name of a variable that you want
to change displayed modify here what I
want to um see for example is value and
I'm going to put text so I want to see
value as text going to save
it and then go here and refresh and you
have value so very basic very simple as
an example you have just created some
kind of visual El inside the page some
kind of
widget but the goal of Ty is really to
make it simple then to be able to modify
your variables synchronize all your
variables varly with tyi so if for
example I want to show to modify this
value 10 to another one I can create
another element let's say I want to
create um for this value a
slider same thing I have this sler going
to refresh my page and I have a sler and
when I'm going to change my sler Ty will
know that he has also to synchronize
this U change of the slider to the text
so there some kind of logic down typi
where if you put this kind of bindings
between variables you're going toiz your
web page and what is really interesting
is with a system of logic you're not
going to for like other P packages but
rerun the code again and again and again
and you have to do some caching kind of
things here like all this logic is done
by that you don't have to waste a lot of
time to be well it's just a way to be
more robust when you create this
application are is the python having a
conversation with like an abstracted
JavaScript library or is it talking to
CSS and HTML time directly it is uh so
we are using for this widgets elements
we're using just uh matal UI as a way to
create this widgets so it's all by I
would I don't know like I have not R
just so I will not really answer your
question we using like overt library
inside got it thank you so much okay um
okay so we have this but of course for
uh time like for data application you
want to write some charts so I'm just
going to import um well just a function
to write some data so this is my
function very basic function um that's
going to create me the list of coign
will the time so just from data we can
have a frame EMP whatever and now I want
to show this
data my application so same thing as
before so I put value
here I want to show it so I'm going to
need a typ element and this typ is a
chart same thing as before I want to
show my data as a chart and then if I
refresh it I have my chart so fact it's
not just like a simple chart it's like
an interactive chart you can zoom in
zoom out if you have traces you can
select traces unselect traces in fact uh
you can do a lot of things because you
are based on plotly so it means that you
own different types of charts Maps bar
charts five charts for charts whatever
um and just to show you the EVS that we
have well we have like input text number
lot of different witches that you can
use typ and for the charts we like
doation for all the types so like I say
by chart charts errors BS and that's
all yeah will the pl dynamically scale
or does the page have to be reloaded for
the to be responsive yeah uh so this
example is not responsive we can just
say you want it to be responsive it's
going to change so it's not just about
the charts even like the layout like one
coln one col one coln if you like just
uh put it in in a phone it's going to
change the layout for yourself okay and
you can also do that
shot so I have application here not
really interesting I know like um to do
that um what maybe I want to do is have
some kind of connection between my
slider and my chart so when I change the
slider is going to change in real time
the the CH so I can do that in multiple
ways like there like few ways to do it
I'm just going to show you two um so
either you use this kind of pull back so
you put a
function um
here I've created just here that I'm
going to
explain so this is a cile function but I
want to call when my function here is
going to change so when my is going to
change it's going to call this function
on slider that I've created with the
state parameter it's always the first
parameter of any functions in and the
state parameter is a type by concept
where you have all your variables in it
because we are multiuser by Design we
need to differentiate between different
users so for example you see that um I
have like 33 eight here for another
clients so for another like application
is going to
be okay
yeah I will have like 10 and so like
this is independent I have two different
state state value equals to 60 State
value is equals 25 so this is way you
need the state you can broadcast the
value to our clients if you want but
every normally like every client is
different so to be by default with the
user so what I'm doing when I go to this
callback I'm saying that state do data
so this chart is going to be changed
corresponding to State
value if I do that if I refresh the
page I will have this kind of
interaction as you can see it's very
very interactive there's like no lag no
nothing whatsoever when you do something
under the is going to be uh very very
fast because we have really this logic
behind it to buy the variables uh and to
not reload everything not code we manage
the events like different ways from
other
packages so we have this way to do it or
if you think it's a bit too um difficult
what you can do is just Aras everything
here and just put in fact
this so if you know a bit about Python
and the fing format this looks like the
format you know
the brackets like this and so it's a bit
like this you can put in P expression
whatever like functions expression
inside directly your elements so now
what's going to do is when I'm going to
change theer I'll Ty another value has
been changed it's going to change the
chart
automatically so I'm doing the same
thing going to refresh I don't have like
my data varable is going to um run the
code and same thing as before can change
the slider to change chart so same thing
as before we manage all the behind you
have to care about it so that's really
very useful like I said this is just a
way to create your application with this
kind of B sytax if you don't like it
there also HTML or this also just a
python way to do it it's the same thing
really the same principle you create
text you create your sler and the chart
and you have the same behavior as one
before so with this logic you create a
wet these all elements create your pages
and then you can create multi page with
use application variously just in few
hours so that's how you do
it so this is the the B part this is how
you create a user interface how you can
create this kind of application like
I've shown you but maybe you want to
have some data overflow some training of
models testing this kind of thing inside
your application and to do that is
really um well hard to do it right now
in Python and so we have also provided a
scenar management system with that like
execution system inside so that's one
I'm going to show you
now this is the user interface I'm going
to go
here to show you how you can create your
own
inside so what you see here is an editor
of pipeline so I am like in Des code in
Des code we have a typy studio VOD
extension and this V Cod extension helps
you edit create your pipeline
configuration for your application so
it's also for the weite but I'm not
going to talk about it and so I can with
this editor create my pipes so this is
just an example of U of one uh it's just
a machine learning problem that I've
created where I have some CSV I'm going
to clean it I'm going to predict and
evaluate so the blue boxes that you see
here are data noes so it's just like
point to your data it can be a python
parameter it can be a csvl have
like lot of predefined types they can be
whatever you want then you have orange
boxes is your task is your P functions
that you want to put inside II can be
really anything you can use any python
libraries sensor flow pyas whatever you
just put this function that you have
created inside that and begin to
orchestrate them with your different
data
sources and so so you you create this
pipeline uh through a type of Studio you
can create a new data node you can put
it to your clean data change the type is
using for example Isle can to CSV you
put the information we're going to be
able to connect to data sources like
this so just so this is just also like
one way to do it so this is with like
graphical editor if you want you can
just do it with python maybe if you have
something that is a bit like dynamic
where you have to do for Loop you need
some kind of thing to configure your
pipelines and data nodes test with the
for Loop and so you will need python so
MTI way to do it but at the end of the
day you have your configuration you have
your data sources your task and now you
want to visualize it you want to
interact with it you want to change the
data to preview it and this is something
really easy to do now with FY so let's
go here I have this main page this is
just really like except from
configuration my application is just
like this I have two P data node and
scenario but I'm going to put in the
dictionary and on it it's really the
only thing that I have it's going to
give me that so I'm going to explain
what everything is so I've created my
configuration of my pipelines to monitor
it to create new ones to create new
predictions with different parameters
and I'm able to use it so this means
that so like I said we we have two pages
scenario and what you see here scenario
and so this scenario page is just
this 20 lines of M so 12 kind of
elements so the first one that you see
is a scenario sctor so scenario is just
a run of your pipeline so like like said
we have some kind of repository of all
your runs like this you can compare
different runs compare predictions um
and have like some kind of bridges three
history of your predictions for example
so this is what is a scenario I have cre
a scenario here and I can create a new
one like another set of
pipeline so scenario two I can put some
custom properties if I want change date
this kind of things I can click on
Create and then I have another set of
pine um now what I have is a data not
viewer so dat View viewer will show you
all the properties of the datae so I
don't have like of them here here is the
history of modification of your data Noe
to see to try
modifications and here is a preview of
the value inside the data Noe if it's
like a basic type like frame array um
date time like this string list kind of
things you can interact with it you can
see it I can modify it so for example
can do change
so it's just a comment I'm going to
change it to
this I think here it's going to change
the value I see this story that I have
changed it I have changed the day of
prediction for my
predictions and then I can click on run
and now like the just have been created
I have done my different task is going
to upgrate me results so this element
also is just is it's a scenario to so I
can delete the scenario can Pro primary
which is another thing can submit it and
you can do a lot of things inside of
this um this element what you see at the
end is just a job selector and dag you
can see all the different jobs um the on
that have been completed failed ConEd
abandoned this kind of things for
example here it is SK this is what um
talked about so here I just ch the
fiction so I'm not going to do this task
again and again and again because I can
just use this cash question
set so this is the scenario page and now
I'm going to show you the DAT on page so
I have created two scenarios and the DAT
on page is just this five lines of mod
basically and you can see here all the
data notes that I have inside my
application that I've created on
predictions so scenario one scenario two
so I can go here the
day that's that's
mytop okay that's good so I have the day
I have the history appication have data
evaluation just a kpi of my predictions
same thing I can have it I can have also
the
predictions and Def I want to so I can
see it as table I can even edit the data
so if it's a SSV behind it I can edit
and write the data like this just using
um or just using this visual element and
I can also if I want to show it as a
chart so you're just going to have like
previews of basic types in this strings
or dat time but also on data frame
you're going to be able to add like
traces to change to X to Y and preview
your data like this so for example to
pre it from friction scenario one and
friction scenario two
so just like this I've just created um
this
configuration two page and then I just
put them here and I have all of these
features just out of the box
basically and so to doation like this is
really simple and then you can
incorporate with other like that we have
uh s just before for example this one
that I've shown you with um the C
information I have ation page where you
see the different PR that I've made for
different dat of pric different
countries I can submit the predictions
can see different charts and explore my
data so that's kind of
it
um so but
maybe your turn my
turn
uh let me just switch uh to my
PC so we have a few minutes left so I'm
going to do a few less slides and then
we'll be
done uh the first question you're going
to ask us after this protection is why
not go to competitors so we have a few
competitors in the python graphical
packages scene uh what we notice in that
scene is that there's basically Two
Poles so on one side there's something
like plotly where it's very complete you
can do anything we with it it's great we
actually use blly but the only issue is
that it's really hard to learn the
learning curve is quite steep so
generally you need a specialist and a
team to use
blly on the other side you have
something that that's very easy to use
but that's not really focused on
production so the best example is
streamlet with streamlet you can do uh
python web apps in Python very
easily the only issue is that streamlet
as soon as you have a big data set a big
model behind or multi-age multi-user
you're going to start seeing that it's
failing uh the app is going to freeze
because the way the events are managed
in the back endend it's not really
focused on production and that's really
the comp compromise we were trying to
find with tyi is we keep the ease of use
of tools like these while remaining
production
oriented uh maybe two last pointers uh
we have our own cloud service so
basically as soon as you have uh coded a
typi app you put it in a zip file and
you upload it to our website and we'll
host it for you for free for a limited
time uh this is really useful for
example if you want to do beta test
testing very early on on your app you
just code it you zip it you upload it to
the website and you can instantly send
it to a better tester and see a do a
better testing
session uh maybe one last thing I'm
going to Showcase is an app we've
written in tyi called talk to tyi uh the
goal with this app was to make um an app
where you could explore CSV data sets
using only natural language so I'm going
to do a quick them of
this does this
work all
right so for example here I have a
simple sales data set about car models
and I can enter a prompt for example I
want to
[Music]
plots
um let's do broad sales by product
line I'm typing with one hand so
go in a pie chart and I've already WR
this
before and this is going to send this to
an llm hosted on a Nour machine Nour
machine which is going to generates
penis code to do data manipulation and
CI code to generate a chart and with
this with this simple bronze we have our
CH that's generated in
tyi uh the goal of this is really to
Showcase typ eyes abilities you can
literally have an llm in the back end
and still have an interface that's
working and this is H set online so if
you want to try it out the URL is up
there uh yeah I'm going to go back to
presentation thank you very much for
your attention um if you have any
questions we might not have time we have
a booth right behind that wall so don't
hesitate to come see us thank
[Applause]
you have three minutes so you can ask
questions but not too difficult ones
please uh can you integrate this with a
react app like let's say I want to put
some more info uh based on like the data
set I use could you be to put that like
part that you didn't into
it I would say the simple way we use my
frame to inate it to inside your
application so it's like well it's not
interactive between your application and
tyi otherwise uh maybe like in fact is
based on flask so if you can do that on
class you can do it with so maybe it's
question yeah cool
similar question here about Bas can you
add your own CSS sty or HTML in the mar
for yeah you can that the thing here
isit the one we have made for Ty you can
change it with python if you want you
can even change it with CSS HTML
whatever so it's up to you it's very
flexible it says here you're on version
three I believe or you just launched it
right so how long this to has been
around like oh uh I say well yeah one
year and half oh so you
got okay
nice how the documentation managed
managed like is
there it is so everything is open source
we just maintain the package so you do
kind of things can to to it but the is
we use MK to
create but yeah can
see this is a for do so this is like how
we build it but this is how it looks
like but yeah you can contribute to it
can tyy all different features we uh
love like having Community anding issues
this kind of things so St to go here
thank
you sorry one more question I think I
saw this is s under flask so if you can
run flask you can run this anywhere Yeah
well yeah you can really do anything
like we talked about Ty by Cloud just a
way for people that don't know anything
about deployment to just it and do it
but of course you can use anything to
just it's very amazing okay
than why uh what made you choose PL as
your visual data uh tools versus
something like B which is also from
doing what you're doing where you're
it's like called to a JavaScript library
Yeah well yeah we use PL because we
thought that it was like the most
complete uh but we not like justly we
see like it's really interesting from
another package like any Library can
just import it that we have seen that a
lot of types are called byly you can
really do
I
thank you so much
and